this is a great test question in a  singles tennis tournament there are 100  players each match pairs two players the  winner advances and the loser is  eliminated assuming a minimum number of  buys games in which a player  automatically advance due to no opponent  how many matches need to be played to  determine a tournament winner there's a  long way to solve this problem which is  to count the number of matches in each  round  so for 100 players there are 50 matches  which leaves 50 players then there are  25 matches which leaves 25 players 25  divided by 2 rounded down is 12  25-12 leaves 13 players we continue this  process and then we count the total  number of matches until one person  remains  this will be a total of 99 matches  but there's a shortcut to solve this  problem  notice that 99 players must lose and  each of the losing players plays exactly  one match therefore there must be 99  matches and that's the short way to  solve the problem